es geht bei dir wurde er macht keine
anstalten sich zu bewegen weil
vielleicht kann mir den wasser ertrinken
lassen
das verleiht den morris george ganz
langsam ganz langsam zurückgehe ich komm
wir wollen nicht wehtun
wir zeigen nur wie beschwingt servus s
kids und herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde click it heute mit dem lieben vieh
nie dabei
und wir spielen auf mtv.com besagtes
spiel namens clique das so funktioniert
ihr lauft ihr über die map am anfang da
ist eile geboten und klickt auf diese
blöcke die bringen unterschiedlich viele
klicks und für die clique ihr
eingesammelt habt könnt ihr dann hier in
dieser kiste inventory heißt die items
kaufen die chance dass sie gute tipps
bekommt ist umso höher je mehr klicks
ihr habt denn ja dann macht man nicht
mehr am start bei herauskommt und am
ende gibt es einen fight nach
soundsoviel minuten ja dann ist die das
ist die ganze magie
ich sag schon mal vorweg wenig natürlich
und in der beschreibung verlinkt wisst
ja wieder dies so und wie sieht's mit
hardy aus aber mir läuft eigentlich also
ich gehe auf der map meisten sind hause
rein wenn der genannten läuft das gehört
das ganze kann kanzler sollen die 50
kinder alles gut läuft sogar 50 sft ja
ich habe jetzt okay jetzt ja ich danke
dir 30 31 wenn ich auf einer insel wo
gerade niemand anders ist jesus hinaus
super weil da gibt es richtig gut
versteckte rote block körper dann immer
so viel auf einmal
ja ich hab kein halt am anfang irgendwie
am spot direkt zwei rotorblätter mit dem
ist ganz klar das ist mein roter budget
damit die 40 von 40-50 klicks mit ein
bisschen glück kannst du über 40 klicks
auch für die wir haben und so dass
gerade 44 ich den regen los findet 42 42
vielleicht kann hier einen edition noch
kommt schon kopfkissen gebt mir wohl
brüder ist nichts mehr
42 hier führt so eine mysteriöse leiter
in baum rein als wenn jetzt nicht 20
millionen klicks drin sind ja ohne
wirklich sind dahinter auf dem schiff
noch keiner auf ein schäfer vom masters
in versuchen auch hier sind rot erinnert
noch keiner geholt ihr wählt mich so
auch charakter schiff ich bin doch eine
insel
kienast oder etwa eine minute zeit das
richtig gut in ja man hat echt genug
zeit die klicks einzusammeln
das unterschätzen niemals ich glaube die
meisten die wollen sich so irgendwie 30
stück und anfangen zu kaufen
aber man könnte quartal auf 0 1 und nun
alle 53 klicks jetzt alles entspannt so
weit ich hoffe ich hoffe ich habe
rechtzeitig noch die dings gemietet in
obs mein mikro ansonsten könnte es sein
das ist jetzt ein bisschen
unterschiedlichen lautes aber wisst ihr
wart werden gerade eben schon so ein
kleines problem mit ok ich hab's gut
wunderbar dankeschön 59 klicks aller go
go go und ich hab mit 66 hab so eine
ganze insel für mich alleine bekomme er
übertreibt nicht chelsea auf der insel
da musste man so durch die komischen
weit weg nach oben gehen und da kommt
mir sicher kann er ja da kann ich jetzt
noch einkaufen alles gut krasser sein
als ich 55 ich riskierte herumzulaufen
um die grace period etwas weiter zu
laufen damit ich mehr weißt du egal es
ändert dann sollte ein bisschen
aufpassen denn noch nicht ganz unrichtig
so das kannte ich ziehe mir immer alles
raus aus dem inventar und dann ziehe ich
mir die ersten treffen mitte willkommen
werden euch jetzt wer wird erwartet dass
das das darf man nicht riskieren als ob
was sagt man immer tories weg wenigkeit
mein mentor ist weg die kiste ist weckt
bei mir echt der wasserdruck vielleicht
die kann man truppen würde ich jetzt
nicht ausschließen kann sein dann ist er
weg
die kannten die liegt dann darum das
ganze mal das alter nicht guckt mal
irgendwo siehst wo ist als ob ich eine
kiste gehabt habe kann man mal machen
mal einmal kann nicht viel falsch machen
in der einkaufs phase
die kiste job und weiß ich ausgerechnet
das wo ist jetzt dieses scheiß sei
leider kommt kiste kommt zu papa
bis dahin steht ein schwein im wasser
was geht oder könnte ich mal ein paar
fans peggy würde ich auch voll ich habe
kein schwein schlachten halt kein
einziger spieler wissen dass richtig
krass wir müssen auch so wenig was
wahrscheinlich daran liegt dass einer
von 24 einfach gerade wie viel sind es
die löcher aber nix machen spiel wird
aber nicht so voll das problem aber
sagen ich es auch cool die leute müssen
sie mal entdecken
ja das hat noch nicht den durchbruch
geschafft also jump league gegen barcas
gehabt dass keine chance irgendwie in
der runde zu kommen so instream meckern
alle willkommen die runden rein und so
weil sind einfach kein premium hat nur
acht runden und non premium keine chance
weil ganz ehrlich wenn ich will nicht
schon reingehe sind die runden schon
voll so dass da kann ja auch leute mit
dem nach seiner okay aber er hat nicht
die richtige equipment problem einzige
möglichkeit wie man hier unter rein
kommt wenn man premium business oder
ganz spät am abend spielt ja das recht
so oder halt premium kaufen wobei ich
muss sagen no hay aber ich find die die
leistung seitens des servers ist jetzt
noch nicht so dass ich sagen würde es
lohnt sich nur predigen zu investieren
dafür muss ein bisschen stabiler sein
oder so ich habe jetzt mal einen
erwischt hier hat er war so schlecht
dass er das so ich hab es dann in
vitoria jetzt geht's wieder weiter schon
120 klicks kann die verwalter leute
einfach gar niemanden es ist richtig
komisch und vor allem nicht sind noch
sieht man so viele blöcke so viele
klicks und das obwohl ich so wenig leute
sind nur da hat eigentlich jeder genug
zeit sich alles die zu holen aber würde
mich wundern wenn einer nicht vorliegt
gleichzeitig haben die leute halt auch
dem motto alter als ob ich okay keine
kleinen unkenrufe am rande gleichzeitig
um die leute zahlen auch ewig zeit sich
auszurüsten
deswegen hat mich echt gewundert dass
der iq mit der er hat nicht nur rüstung
hätten nichts an
nicht so kleiner windkraft mit möglicher
kann sich sein erstes game
klaus kommt ist hier ich bin immer
verzweifelt auf der suche ist okay klaus
gamers auch da gibt es einen kompass in
der runde kriegt man bin glaube ich noch
vier spieler da sind
einer muss auch sterben dafür so zwei
inventories wie kriegt man ich glaube
dann kriegt man seine eigene story
angezeigt oder das von dem mann getötet
hat mit der kiste
man kriegt ein eigenes immer gleich okay
ich habe es halt meine 50/50 glaube ich
nicht die man meistens getrennt
hier ruht jetzt verballert schildmann
leute so muss ich die person geführt
haben die wir spenden
ich habe einfach noch 19 klicks über und
kann nicht mehr ausgeben hat mache ich
damit kann ich die kann ich dir meine
klicks sprechen kannst du was anfangen
also wissentlich 23 sogar schon
verzaubert alter wo aber hier klickt man
immer noch keine ahnung
das habe ich noch nicht bekommen hast du
noch nie punch auf dem bogen ja ja echt
auf level 1 ja also du bist ja anders
taxieren den du einfach rechts gekauft
den german travel mast mit einem alten
und dann kriegst du irgendwann zufällig
essentials kosten zufällig felix ok
krass weil normalerweise im echten bis
jemand der hat einfach auch nicht ich
glaube der kauft gerade steht man vor
dem bemerkt der kelch spd steht warum
nicht guck dir das mal an ich komme der
kauf nämlich grad und täglich vor dem tv
oder video auf die tür aufgehen da facto
ok auf jeden fall sicher und nahmen
ich laufe prima ich musste ganz einfach
richtig weist der tür
er merkt sich nicht jeder einfach neben
dem und macht gar nichts und die kassen
heftige combo laune richtig heftige
combo naja also bogen
der fristlos richtig der ist ja ich
glaub ich eine seerose ich habe ihn
erwischt sehr witzig mal zusammen den
trecker vielleicht trägst du mich sogar
dann kannste mal kurz herkommen den
kollegen jahren schon sehr umstritten
weil inventar war davor ich hab keinen
trecker bekommen echt
what the [ __ ] das ist problem weil wenn
man zu viel heute gilt das emmental war
voll und dann kriegt man keinen trecker
leute also merkt euch im leben nicht so
viele leute umbringen
denn daraus resultieren immer nachteile
das ist kaum wahrscheinlich
ich habe anfragen nicht ob der typ
solange einkauft oder was er da macht
wieder echt schon alles an dir außerdem
chess plate aber steht es hat zwei
minuten in die ecke und einer plane und
ich schätze seine kiste in der hand und
weiß ich was der macht und die chance
zwei minuten zu oder dass noch einer
dass nach einer op das heißt wir haben
jetzt alle gefunden also deiner sind
noch viele leute glaube ich das bist du
ein mensch der regel in die kiste
ich und mein lob kassiert auch wieder
schöne bogen ist
du hast also jetzt keine absicht
irgendwann zu greifen ich gucke mir so
ein bisschen zu ich warte bis es sich
bewegt oder sowas dann kannst du mal der
komponenten anguckt mehr trifft mich
heftig krass ich versuche ich versuche
hier auszuschalten
aber ich keine gute position hat es halt
im land ich bin dem wasserrad ist
relativ kaka damit den bogen
man wird gerne wird minecraft ich weg
ist da jetzt geht man über das boot
drauf gucken wo ihr seid concentration
richtig viele blogger erfolg für items
noch feuer sieht er mich ich habe die
angie weg so jetzt frisst festes noch
ein komm ja noch eine und
wenn ich wüsste wo ihr seid die wildnis
kann gucken kannst du kannst aber
niemand aus dem checker rausnehmen
leider nicht ganz ehrlich wie sieht das
gerade bei euch aus du kämpfst einfach
ist einfach gerade die ganze zeit in der
nähe des typen und er bemerkte ich nicht
da bin ja das steht hier einfach da hat
er steht bei so einer treppe nach oben
einfach einem brand in seiner werbung
drinnen also er kann eigentlich nur noch
vorne gucken kann niemand seiner auf der
seite für den könnte man aber merkt sich
wenn ich vor ihm steht oder ist die
ganze aufgabe
ja ich entweder mutter zum essen gerufen
oder jobs hat eine predigt halten soll
klar shopping queen
dabei hat ja schon so viel rüstung
deswegen weil sie ja anscheinend wie man
shoppt wichtig sind kann es locker
locker wurde er zum essen gerufen
es kann gut sein ja aber glücklich wie
das üblich schockiert war ist heute ein
bisschen im preis also ich bin es gerade
hier und da der insel amrum steppen und
sucht dich um den andere typen mit ihr
wissen auf einem der boote
jetzt gibts die schau dann im inneren
des bootes carrasco rhein fire
eingedrückt war jetzt ab maschen gleich
wieder hundert tage okay jetzt schon
dann verfällt nicht okay es darum geht
keiner als erstklassig gerade gedacht
hat erfolgen wie souverän afghani wurde
auch zum essen gerufen einfach mitten im
kampf gegen erst kämpfen und mich nicht
durch stück klassische unterhaltung aus
meinem haushalt weist jetzt jetzt habe
ich es aber okay jetzt hab ich dich dem
trecker drin alles ganz locker
da kann ich mit meinem typ mir anschauen
ja jetzt können wir die mailboxen und
armes land
es kann ja sein vielleicht ist in die
runde und hat sich so die sachen
gekauften sowas und darf sich dann so
okay ich mache mit musik alles raus
getappt ist so ein lied raus und hat
vergessen dass im spiel ist ich glaube
er komponiert gerade über das steht ja
noch die ganzen salat isst macht keine
anstalten sich zu bewegen westler waren
auf jeden fall eine ist jetzt ein
bisschen mehr der schillernden sieht das
leben alles bisschen entspannter und wir
können dir darunter boxen
oh ja vielleicht kann mir den wasser
ertrinken lassen
das war nach dem 9
wir müssen aufpassen dass keine falschen
krieg george ganz langsam ganz ganze
gesellschaft brücke ich komm wir wollen
nicht wehtun
wir zeigen nur wie man schwimmt ja jetzt
alles klar
das reicht es schon ich glaube schon ja
hatte ich wird hier noch tiefer
das reicht auf jeden fall recht okay
das ist ja wie das ist es nicht so
niveau von folter oder sowas
bis dahin hatte gelüftet ich glaube
jetzt sich ausgeloggt ich komplimente
hört sich vielleicht geschlossen oder so
schmalen wir wollten nicht ertrinken
lassen
vielleicht hat der händler video ich
glaube einfach so lange ab dass er für
den teilort bekommen hat dem das kann
auch sagen ja auch schade letztlich
ertrunken ich lebe jetzt echt gerne so
ein prozess inszeniert sind obwohl es
zum tod durch ertrinken verurteilt oder
wie es sehr gut dass man denn ford
machen oder alles klappt und sogar
voraus hier oben hier oben ist ganz gut
danke versetzte davon seit mai muss hier
kurz ein bisschen so organisieren war
noch mit den items noch mitte mit den
items soll ich sagen komplett alles kann
komplett entertainment okay sagt eine
rally bis ich bin so weit über ok alles
klar
deren verein gut 3 2 1 los geht's nicht
so drin bei mir gerade bei mir auch
nicht einmal getroffen bisher richtig
schlecht ich weiß aber bei unserer
letzten aufnahme du hast mir hast mich
ein bisschen theater ja da war ich aber
noch im boot
wie wir aber selbst öffnete schließlich
damit selben tag auch selbst doch wo was
nein keine fahne als ob es keinen fall
gut ist gut ist gut
okay ich hab irgendwie keine kinder
bekommen ein herz die ganze zeit
schlecht
ich hatte ich natürlich voll unterstützt
die ganze hat aber die ganze zeit ein
herz gehabt und habe vergessen sie also
leute zwei dinge die im leben auf jeden
fall nicht vergessen sollte bringt nicht
zu viele leute um
und er ist immer sonst geht schlecht für
euch aus wenig ist unten in der
beschreibung verlinkt wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder hau 3 macht's gut